[Music]
the scp foundation has a long history of
experience with humanoid anomalies from
simple reality benders like scp-239
to strange transplants from other
universes like
scp-2273 but one of the oldest strangest
and most lethal humanoid anomalies in
the foundation's considerable cabinet
isn't a superhuman or a soldier it is a
man known only as herr hirog on first
glance
scp-542's containment protocol is
seemingly standard he is allowed to
request personal items and furniture for
his cell so long as they are blunt and
cannot be used to cut skin reasonable
enough and many such requests have been
granted the ones denied include nail
files clippers and a surgery kit which
has been set aside for testing only but
continuing
scp-542 requires some special attention
too a blood transfusion every week on
request and even an organ transplant
conducted by foundation doctors should
any of his own organs begin to fail
scp-542
offers to do the surgery himself but is
repeatedly denied to understand the
story of her herod we must look back
through time to several years before
scp-542's containment over the past
three years there have been a violent
string of murders across america england
and germany interpol and the fbi are
stumped not only by the wide range of
attacks anywhere from 45 to 60 murders
across three countries but by the brutal
nature of the attacks the victims were
found in various states of disassembly
body parts missing and tissue removed
they set up crime scenes and conducted
complex investigations but they were
simply unable to find their man in one
month four people in germany were
assaulted with the muscle tissue and
bone removed from all of their limbs
three of them died from their injuries
before help could arrive and the fourth
was an american woman staying at a shady
german hotel the only reason she
narrowly survived the horrific attack
was because of the actions of her
neighbor a foundation agent passing
through town he heard sounds of fighting
in the room next door at three in the
morning and broke down the door to hell
unaware of the horrific scene he would
find a huge misshapen man best described
as a frankenstein's monster his skin was
a patchwork of different shades stitched
and grafted together his chest was
sunken in his arms were grotesquely long
for his body and his face was skeletal
and gaunt this creature that would come
to be named
scp-542 was hunched over the fully
conscious woman vivisecting her leg to
remove the sinew and bone in shock the
agent pulled his weapon and fired at the
creature which escaped through the
window unharmed the authorities were
called and the woman survived although
without her right leg just before being
amnesticized the woman provided a
statement to the foundation she had been
staying in germany for a few days when
she saw a strange man on her usual bus
one day even though it was summer the
man was draped and wrapped in layers of
heavy coats jackets and a hat though his
face completely obscured the woman could
tell he was staring at her from the back
of the bus thinking it was just some
creep she ignored him and got off at her
stop for three days she continued to
take the bus and ignore the strange man
sitting in the back then on the fourth
day when she got off the bus that night
and went to her hotel room she found the
window open and the lights off and
assumed she had been burglarized but as
soon as she opened the door she realized
she wasn't alone two freakishly long
arms with disjointed hands grabbed her
ankles from under the bed and brought
her crashing to the floor before she
knew what was happening she was tied to
the bed and the hulking hunchback was
retrieving a surgical set and sharpening
his knives and tools fearing the worse
she began to scream and the agent hurt
her but by the time he broke in and shot
his weapon the creature had already done
too much damage to her leg the victim
was amnesticized and told her leg had
been amputated in a car crash the
foundation took over the investigation
from interpol realizing this wasn't some
regular serial killer this was a
creature a predator and to find it they
had to hunt scp-542
like a predator after a long tracking in
manhunt across europe
scp-542 was brought into foundation
custody and research into this creature
could begin to understand the story of
her hirog the researchers were expecting
an animal or a monster something they
could study and dissect which is why
they were so shocked when the monster
began speaking in tongues german french
polish before settling on english all in
a sharp german accent the beast was
introducing itself
[Music]
german for mr surgeon preliminary
investigations revealing much about
scp-542
and confirmed the agent's initial
impression was correct here hiruk is a
modern frankenstein's monster his
anatomy has been warped and malformed as
the agent observed his skin is a
patchwork of large chunks of skin
grafted or sewn to each other no two of
which seem to come from the same person
his rib cage is warped and twisted with
all the ribs jutting out in different
directions and both his arms are
different sizes though both are
incredibly muscular and far too long for
his body attached to each is a hand but
filled with far more joints than any
normal hand allowing him to bend his
fingers in almost any direction his
spine is hunched and twisted like a
snake and the skin stretched tight over
his skull reveals a sunken cranium and a
mouth with far far too many teeth none
of them from the same source and not all
of them human and these are all simply
the externally obvious and most
grotesque modifications foundation staff
have conducted intense medical research
ranging from x-rays to comprehensive dna
testing
scp-542's bone and muscle structures are
asymmetrical revealing the left and
right sides of his body come from
different sources in fact they reveal
that almost all of his organs and body
parts have been replaced with other body
parts from different sources his dna is
heavily fragmented beyond all logic by
any reasonable measure
scp-542 should have died a long time ago
instead he is able to accept many blood
types and organ transplants without so
much as discomfort much less the serious
autoimmune response that any normal
person would get not to mention he is
able to stay perfectly aware even while
performing complex brain surgery on
himself
herrhirug's history is as enigmatic and
mysterious as the question of how he
remains alive he claims he was once a
simple doctor from germany dreadfully
normal until the great war began the
foundation has deduced this to mean that
he began his modifications to his body
between the world wars but it appears
herrhirig wasn't just a monster on the
outside he claims to have worked for the
nazis in world war ii as they conducted
brutal human experimentation
which he described as boring the exact
nature and timeline of how he modified
himself without dying at some point is
similarly mysterious he professes that
he didn't work alone for more complex
surgeries such as implanting his second
heart or replacing parts of his spinal
cord he had a team of helpers who and
where the surgical assistants are now is
a mystery if they're even alive after
all the foundation has ample evidence
here herrig is able and willing to kill
people for their parts after all this
exhaustive research on scp-542
you'd be forgiven for thinking that he
is some kind of mad scientist driven
insane by his experimentation on his own
body while no one can answer why hiro
kills except himself he is almost
frighteningly sane this hulking
monstrosity enjoys reading his anatomy
textbooks which he requests on a regular
basis along with filling out crossword
puzzles in german he's friendly too
described as surprisingly pleasant by
the research team he holds long
intellectual conversations on topics
ranging from science and biology and
medicine to politics and history which
he seems to recount with startling
accuracy in fact tissue testing has
failed to return a definitive age for
the surgeon he's incredibly skilled at
the game of chess and the research team
is allowed to play with him as a method
of interview
scp-542 displays fluency in a variety of
european languages though he prefers his
supposedly native german at first the
research team was enthused with his
presence even if he was a little
terrifying having a brilliant doctor to
converse with was a great distraction
for them his ability to heal from
intense surgery with almost no organ
rejection or allergic reactions was
considered a medical miracle and rather
than locking him up and throwing away
the key the research team decided to use
him to try and harness this incredible
power for modern medicine his books and
notes captured along with him reveal
surgical techniques and methods far more
advanced than considered possible when
they were written for his part scp-542
was happy to comply he enjoyed
performing surgery on himself with an
audience using himself as a living
cadaver to explain his manner of surgery
and the functions of the body
unfortunately observing him this close
carried a risk none of the researchers
realized until it was too late you see
her hirig isn't just a friendly old
surgeon his body runs off second-hand
parts and is constantly failing organs
stop functioning blood flow ceases parts
of his body grow gangrenous and necrotic
scp-542 is able to anomalously detect
when this is happening he is perfectly
and acutely aware of his own bodily
functions like digestion and perstasis
and he knows exactly when one of his
organs is starting to give up or his
flesh is beginning to decay when this
happens the surgeon undergoes a drastic
transformation his pleasant exterior
evaporates he grows moody and withdrawn
snapping at people and avoiding
conversation he spends long periods of
time observing people using his ability
to sense how well their body is and then
when he senses an opening he strikes
just like his murders in europe he picks
the body of his victims clean of their
body parts he needs and lets them die of
blood loss then he performs the surgery
to replace his own failing organs with
the new ones and returns to his usual
demeanor this monstrous jekyll-hyde
relationship isn't purely need-based
either the research team has discovered
that here hirog will also dissect people
simply for the joy of the act in one
regrettable incident a sewing kit was
left behind in this cell several hours
later guards discovered a d-class sewn
to the mattress in
scp-542's cell with the surgeon
carefully and gleefully extracting his
organs scp-542
her herik is a walking encyclopedia of
medical and surgical knowledge but all
that knowledge comes from
experimentation on himself and on
unwilling victims the foundation has put
him to use in certain projects but all
activity with him is to be strictly
monitored and regulated despite
appearances scp-542
isn't a person he is a predator and an
exceptionally skilled and dangerous one
at that one moment of inattentiveness
can result in a fate much worse than
death around him but you can rest
assured that if something does happen
your parts won't go to waste now go
check out
scp-049 the plague doctor captured scp
animation and story and scp immortal dr
bright explained scp animation for more
anomalous scp doctors